nearly a third of the Earth's land is
covered by forests trillions of trees
operating what is essentially one of the
largest and cleanest factories in the
world working 24/7 to lock in carbon and
produce oxygen they've been doing
millions of years they are remarkably
good at it they are better than a
machine that we've managed to come up
with less fast these glorious organisms
which have this this ability to become
the biggest the tallest the fattest
things we've ever grown on the planet
and they then have this ability to lock
up carbon into a great structure like
this this amazing beech tree in fantasy
John Stokes has dedicated his life to
trees and his worker the tree council is
coming to fruition
the British government has just
committed to reduce the UK's net
greenhouse gas emissions to zero by 2050
the big part of achieving that goal is
to dramatically increase the number of
trees planted right across the country
the climate change committee wants
around 3 billion new trees in the next
three decades it doesn't have to be just
forests we're gonna have to put trees
everywhere to make this to make this
work we're gonna have to think about
gardens because people can plant trees
in their gardens everyone counts you're
going to be talking about parks going to
be talking about streets we're talking
about hedgerows and if you do all of
those different places then absolutely
we've got more than enough space the
impact that woodland and trees have on
capturing co2 cannot be underestimated
and the UK lags behind its European
neighbors when it comes to the number of
trees it's why the committee is making
dramatic and ambitious plans to increase
the number of trees being planted right
across the UK currently forests and
woodlands cover only 13% of the UK with
the largest areas in Scotland
Northumberland and Hampshire the climate
change committee report recommends
increasing forest coverage to 17% the
report calls for at least 30,000
hectares of trees to be planted each
year until 2050 the UK is woefully
behind that and the current recommend a
of 20,000 hectares a year in 2018 a
little over nine thousand hectares were
planted planting that many trees as well
as boosting active woodland management
would increase the net amount of carbon
trapped in UK forests and woodland to 22
metric tonnes per year by 2050 66
year-old dick Walters has been a local
tree warden in East Lee Hampshire for
the last 30 years he's among volunteers
who've transformed an overgrown woodland
into a thriving forest
he's now passing on his wisdom to
younger generations it's not taught in
school now a lot of children at 10 or 11
don't know where an apple came from I
haven't seen an oak tree and don't
understand a process of nature and what
nature does there our answer for the
future
it's one of 6,000 tree wardens across
the country who are playing a vital role
in ensuring our trees and looked after
but increasing tree cover in the UK by
such a large amount can't be left just
local groups alone it'll need major
projects investment and new forests
created from scratch 25 years ago this
area of the Midlands was mining
territory coal fields left desolate as
the industry declined it's now the
National Forest 200 square miles of
regenerated land thriving with millions
of trees with more being planted every
year a success story in turning
wastelander woodland carbon emitting to
carbon absorbing there are sustainable
Sue Anderson helped plant the first
trees we're creating a whole new forest
here been going 20 odd years we began
with about 6 percent woodland cover and
we're now at 20% and we're heading
through a roundabout third so all around
you you will see young trees but also
trees that are 20 20 25 years
sold beginning to feel like a mature
forest the national forest is living
proof that creating vast new woodlands
can be achieved in a relatively short
space of time even on this large scale
small armies of volunteers are needed
this group keeps one area of the
national forest in check in return for
firewood to sell those in charge say
managing the forest is just as important
as planting it you can plant the
woodland and it will grow the trees will
grow just fine but if you do the
management the trees will be growing a
better efficiency and therefore
capturing more carbon where will the
land come from to create new forests
like this the climate change committee
says a 5th the farmland must be
converted to alternative use such as
tree planting we live in a country where
space is already at a premium
despite that even in urban city centres
there are opportunities this patch of
land in Portsmouth was bombed in the war
but in the last five years has been
transformed into a community orchard now
it's a fantastic area and the local
people love it the children from the
play park come across and join in to
plant things people walking through
enjoy it in urban environments these
these little pockets of heaven these are
really important taking action to save
our environment is no longer a sideline
issue in politics we've got a target 11
million trees being planted by the end
of this Parliament but we've got
aspirations beyond that and in our 25
year environment plan we set out a
target or aspiration they're moving from
10% free cover in England to 12% that's
the equivalent of covering an area the
size of Dorset entreats so there is real
ambition there but we realize there's
more we need to do it's this momentum
that could see plans for billions of
trees grow into reality I've been doing
this for 30 years and I have genuinely
never felt more excited than I am at the
moment about this complete opportunity
that exists that's being realized by all
age groups and
across the country and it is fantastic
to see the young people realizing that
they they they need to be thinking about
doing something tree by tree planting
projects across the country are already
underway the aim to plant now to lock
away carbon for hundreds of years to
come
Dan Whitehead Sky News